[Musica]
il 2000 leggendario programmatore della
silicon valley bill joy scrive un
editoriale su wired dal titolo
abbastanza eloquente il futuro non ha
bisogno di noi
l'argomento di gioia è molto semplice se
continuiamo a migliorare la nostra
capacità di costruire macchine che
eseguono compiti complessi
siamo molto vicini a inventare l'ultima
macchina la macchina e che renderà tutti
noi
superfluo ed obsoleti avanti 20 anni
2019 la stampa e la silicon valley tutta
da cui provengo stanno tentando di
convincerli ogni giorno che siamo
vicinissimi a un mondo in cui la
profezia di joy si sta avverando
cosiddetta quarta rivoluzione
industriale in quella delle gae
dell'intelligenza artificiale delle
macchine pensanti
io sono jacopo sono il fondatore di una
start up che si chiama tuso oggi riposo
con altre due persone molto più serie di
me evidentemente vivo a san francisco e
mi occupo di intelligenza artificiale
ho accettato l'invito questo talk
principalmente per spiegare ai miei
genitori cosa faccio tutto il tempo
dall'altra parte dell'oceano hayat e san
francisco silicon valley
io sono sulla carta la persona perfetta
per venire a convincervi del verbo che
viene dalla california ma se vi
aspettate un talk la silicon valley oggi
rimarrebbe profondamente delusi la
verità che non vi biasimo se avete un po
creduta tutta questa retorica delle
macchine pensanti negli ultimi anni
intelligenza artificiale ha raggiunto
risultati straordinari riuscendo a fare
cose che prima erano considerati è
tipicamente umane come ad esempio
riconoscere gattini su youtube che
un'attività che so che tutti voi sta
molto a cuore è un po più seriamente a
battere il campione mondiale di go go è
una specie di versione cinese è molto
complicata degli scacchi e il campione
mondiale di go consiglio della foto non
era particolarmente contento dell'esito
della partita
l'intesa tv c'è l'attuale progredisce
principalmente per quelle che vengono
chiamate reti neurali che vengono di
solito rappresentate con questi vaghi
schemi in cucina
delle connessioni da cui insomma il nome
reti neurali questa vaga ispirazione al
cervello umano quello che succede che
voi date in pasto un input a questa rete
che lo processa un esempio l'immagine di
un gatto e mi dice cosa c'è su queste
immagini ad esempio un gatto la verità è
che per capire dove la silicon valley si
sbaglia non serve sapere davvero cos'è
una rete neurale tutte le formule che
spiegano come funziona
in particolare vorrei che vi dimenticate
qualsiasi cosa sapete sulle reti neurali
intanto poco e pensate per oggi alle
reti neurali come una scatola magica
sulla scatola che inizialmente
completamente vuota a cui voi date
immagini di cani e gatti una dopo
l'altra
ogni volta che mettete un immagine in
questa scatola magica di te questo un
cane in questo è un gatto
la scatola magica perché dopo che voi
fate questa cosa 100.000 volte 10
milioni di volte
la scatola effettivamente da sola
stavano in grado di distinguere cosa è
un cane è cos'è un gatto quello che però
non vi dicono sulle copertine patinate
di wired di time magazine
e quanto costa imparare cos'è un gatto
su youtube imparare cosa è un reato con
youtube ha richiesto 16.000 processori è
l'equivalente di 10 milioni di gattini
che sono veramente tanti gatti v butter
un essere umano ago ha richiesto cinque
milioni di partite ovvero l'equivalente
di 500 anni umani di gioco il solo costo
di elettricità di programmare per google
di programmare quel computer è stimato
in termini di 25 milioni di dollari
quindi la prossima volta che vi
lamentate della vostra bolletta
elettrica pensate a quella di google è
un'idea abbastanza intuitiva in realtà
che anche noi abbiamo nella vita di
tutti i giorni se io domani vado a
monaco due giorni torno e parlo tedesco
perfettamente che sarete ammirati dalla
mia capacità di imparare penserete che
io sia un genio
sempre in germania 40 anni sposò una
tedesca lavoro per un'azienda tedesca e
faccio figli in germania torno e parlo
tedesco questa cosa ovviamente molto
utile comunque praticamente ma nessuno
penserà che per questa cosa io sia un
genio quello che succede quando la
silicon valley vuole convincervi che
mondo di bill joy sta arrivando e dalle
porte quindi
e che lo slittamento tra il concetto di
intelligenza che usiamo per noi umani e
il concetto di apprendimento che usiamo
per un e umani e quello che invece
usiamo per le macchine è profondamente
diversa ed è in questo slittamento che
sta fondamentalmente l'inganno facciamo
un esperimento purtroppo non intera
farmi cantare non so quanti di voi
abbiano visto ho mai in vita vostra un
arco hard siamo la mano quanti hanno
visto un arco hard nessuno un po troppo
qualcuno
ero preparato perché nessuno dicesse
qualcosa pazienza
la cosa bella non è tanto cos'è un art
park è un mammifero sub sahariano la
cosa bella è questa anche quando gli ho
detto harvard tutti voi avete guardato
questa porzione dell'immagine senza che
vi dicesse alcunché perché perché avete
riconosciuto delle orecchie degli occhi
insomma vede riconosciuto tutti i tratti
tipici con cui mammifero si differenzia
dal proprio sfondo non solo dopo un solo
esempio voi siete in grado di capire che
altre foto di harvard con diversa
inclinazione e diverse in qualche modo
inquadratura sono hartford e cosa invece
superficialmente simile come un
formichiere non lo è un solo esempio
quanto una rete neurale una scatola
magica vede per la prima volta un art
art
non so come guardare in tutte le
porzioni dell'immagine possono
potenzialmente contenere un art art
è questo il motivo profondo perché
dovete fargliene vedere 10 milioni
perché se voi fate vedere 10 milioni di
immagini diverse dove la falda in
posizioni diverse e girato con la luce
senza luce
l'intelligenza artificiale può
finalmente capire cos'è il mammifero e
cos'è lo sfondo se passiamo dalle
immagini al linguaggio che il mio campo
di studio le cose sono ancora peggio
questo è un classico test di analogia
lessicale molto semplice il cane abbaia
come il gatto ovviamente miagola io
posso prendere il mio portatile che
spara utilizzare e migliore algoritmi
intelligenza artificiale conosciuti e in
circa tre ore
leggendo le prevalenti 10.000 volte
guerra e pace riusciamo ad avere un
sistema che risponde a questo quesito
ma questo non è l'unico modo di fare le
cose esiste un sistema fisico molto
costoso soprattutto in america dove vivo
molto complesso che risolve questo
problema in maniera molto più facile
cosa incredibile è che alcuni di voi
avranno già questo sistema fisico a casa
qualcuno di voi ne avrà
che più di uno questo sistema lo
chiamiamo comunemente bambino e per chi
non lo sapesse una versione in scala di
un essere umano
il bambino risolve questo taschino circa
tre secondi ovviamente una volta che
vuoi semplicemente indicato un gatto e
ditte miagola un bambino è così bravo a
imparare che tra i 12 18 mesi impara 75
nuove parole al mese
un bambino è così brava imparare che
quando vi cadono le chiavi della
macchina e di te una parolaccia e
bambino era impara senza che voi lo
vogliate ore 3 ore 10 mila volte guerre
pace quella pace lungo ragazzi ne hanno
detto per bacino 13 secondi
è questo il vero gap tra l'intelligenza
artificiale che abbiamo oggi è la vera
intelligenza a distanza tra il mondo in
cui noi siamo il mondo di billy joy è la
distanza tra le tre ore e i tre secondi
la buona notizia è che possiamo
utilizzare i bambini per costruire le
macchine migliori cercando di carpire un
po i segreti di questo sistema
incredibile cosa un esperimento standard
in cui abbiamo sottoposto un bambino di
sei mesi a un piccolo gioco c'è una
rotaia con un trenino come vedete il
trenino scende dalla rotaia
lo schermo giallo si solleva e in
qualche modo si vede un cubo che sta
dietro alla rotaia fin qui niente di
nuovo semplicemente un trenino che
scende a questo punto noi inganniamo da
buoni sperimentatori questo bambino di
sei mesi e facciamo esattamente la
stessa cosa ma quando lo schermo sale
dopo che il trenino passato
mettiamo che il cubo in mezzo alla
rotaia
ovviamente se non avesse infilato il
bambino questo è fisicamente impossibile
nel nostro mondo i corpi soldi non si
compenetrano al bambino non sa niente di
fisica bambino a sei mesi bambino anche
se voleste spiegarglielo non potrebbe
capirlo qui interessante capire cosa
succede nella testa di un bambino
qual è il bambino quando il bambino vede
il mondo possibile il mondo normale il
bambino è contento come tutti i bambini
immagino che vedono un trenino scorrere
sulla rotaia
quando un bambino vede un mondo
impossibile che fisicamente non può
accadere questo cosa succede
il bambino guarda diversi secondi e
sette di sperimentare in qualche modo
domandandosi cos'è che nella realtà
tendenzialmente non va bene ma c'è una
cosa ancora più interessante quando voi
prendete il trenino che si comporta in
maniera impossibile e la date al bambino
il bambino farà questo
il bambino cioè testerà la solidità del
trenino
infatti se voi invece che fare questo
esperimento prendete una macchinina è
sempre ingannando il bambino è
facilissimo che andare i bambini sei
mesi apparentemente è in grande bambino
di sei mesi voi prendete una macchinina
e fingete che vada verso l'alto invece
che caschi come la gravità predice e
l'ha dato in mano al bambino sapete il
bambino cosa fa la prende e la fa cadere
dal seggiolone per testare che la
macchinina effettivamente risponde alle
leggi di gravità
queste sono due differenze fondamentali
tra come costruiamo oggi l'intelligenza
artificiale i bambini la prima è che per
imparare in fretta dobbiamo già sapere
qualcosa nel caso del bambino il bambino
già la nozione della fisica in qualche
modo intuitiva nel cervello e la usa per
imparare la seconda è che il bambino non
sta fermo come una rete neurale
aspettando che voi le date decine di
milioni di immagini di gatti il bambino
come un piccolo scienziato utilizza il
mondo canta sempre fare degli
esperimenti e capire un po come funziona
la realtà la buona notizia è che in
realtà possiamo già usare questi
principi per costruire i sistemi che
funzionano nella realtà e noi nel nostro
piccolo abbiamo incominciato a farlo
prendiamo il caso molto semplice con cui
tutti voi sarete immagino familiari
comprare vestiti online andate su un e
commerce
scrivete una parola tubino premete invio
quello che succede dall'altra parte che
c'è una intelligenza artificiale che in
qualche modo deve provare a capire il
significato di questa nuova parola come
facciamo a programmare un intelligenza
artificiale che risolva questo problema
dobbiamo fare come abbiamo visto fanno i
bambini
la prima cosa che dobbiamo dare
l'intelligenza artificiale sono delle
nozioni in qualche modo a priori che
spiegano qual è il nostro dominio di
riferimento non è la fisica questo è un
dominio un po più mondano sono appunto i
vestiti ma è utile che la nostra
intelligenza artificiale sabbia che i
vestiti si dividano ad esempio in abiti
gonne jeans e che a loro volta gli abiti
siano fatti di un certo colore un certo
materiale o abbiano invece un certo
stile
il secondo ingrediente che abbiamo visto
è l'esperimento come facciamo a far
sperimentare un motore di ricerca un
intelligenza artificiale che sta sul
vostro browser
beh ovviamente usando voi come cavia
tutte le volte che vuoi finite su un
sito che ha una di queste
intelligenza artificiale che imparano
come bambini tutte le volte voi cliccate
su un prodotto quando l'intelligenza
artificiale vi propone i risultati del
motore di ricerca
voi siete di fatto l'equivalente
metaforico del tavolino contro quel
bambino stava schiacciando il trenino
intesi a striscia la sta usando voi e il
vostro feedback e la vostra intelligenza
per imparare utilizzando l'ambiente in
maniera molto efficiente
quello che succede quando voi utilizzate
intelligenze artificiali che funzionano
in questo modo e non nel modo in cui la
maggior parte del mondo appunto sta in
qualche modo facendo in questo momento
potete imparare che tubino investito
sono di fatto sinonimi con solo 10
esempi 10 esempi non sono tre secondi
però nel continuo tra tre ore e 3
secondi 10 esempi sono un primo passo
chiaramente verso la giusta direzione
perché questa cosa dovrebbe interessare
tutti e non solo le persone che come me
chiaramente stanno cercando una scusa
per stare dall'altra parte del mondo
rispetto ai propri genitori due motivi
il primo è pratico sono tantissimi
ambiti della vostra vita ad esempio
ambiti coperti dalla privacy o ambiti
coperti dai venti molto rari in cui
neanche volendo potreste mai accumulare
10 milioni di esempi e non vorremmo
utilizzare le macchine e tutte le cose
che le macchine sanno fare meglio di
loro di no in questi ambiti e quindi
imparare con 10 esempi è un ottimo modo
per poterlo utilizzare in modo più vasto
il secondo motivo forse ancora più
importante e sociale
in un mondo in cui i benefici
dell'intelligenza artificiale delle
macchine sono appannaggio di kompany di
aziende che possono raccogliere milioni
miliardi
centinaia di miliardi di dati è un mondo
in cui pochissime company comandano
fondamentalmente il progresso il mondo
in cui la nostra visione del futuro è
fondamentalmente delegata a quelli che
se lo possono permettere
ecco programmare macchine che funzionano
un po più come i bambini in qualche modo
democratizza l'accesso a tutte le nuove
tecnologie ea tutto quello che di buono
noi le macchine insieme possiamo fare
l'intelligenza artificiale ha fatto una
serie di progressi spaventosi negli
ultimi dieci anni e non saremo
certamente noi allegarlo però
intelligenza artificiale vera l'unico
modo per produrla e ispirarsi in qualche
modo l'unica vera intelligenza che noi
abbiamo a nostra disposizione che
appunto e quella degli esseri umani e in
particolare a quella dei bambini
insomma possiamo proprio dire con buona
pace di bill joy che rata al futuro non
ha mai avuto così tanto bisogno di noi
grazie
[Musica]